news now viewer reached out to us about
a bumpy ride she and others near Sunrise
Manor are forced to experience daily we
sent reporter Ryan Matthey out to Vegas
Valley Drive and lamb to check it out he
joins us live from there with apparently
a road full of potholes
right
a lot of potholes Kirsten and actually
that viewer says she's lived in the area
for over a decade potholes like the one
right next to me have grown larger and
larger ever since she says and they're
not only unsightly but damaging costly
and seemingly not being addressed
appropriately
I love to do crafting 87 year old May
Simpson says she runs errands three
times a week but the drive isn't smooth
we've been in a Perpetual cycle of oh
Haze another hole Yeah now here comes
another home these are what she's met
with pothole after pothole after pothole
directly outside her senior living
community
I drove it myself between Nellis and
lamb on Vegas Valley Drive she says
temporary fixes don't last long they
come with buckets of tar the trucks come
down they hit that car it's gone
divots that cause damage I have had
replaced I've had all four shots
replaced on my car ampo safety concerns
for those driving it one day
somebody's going to hit one of those
potholes go to swim and I'm going to be
behind him I apologize to Samara we got
lost in the shuffle the stretch of road
maintained by the county is in
commissioner tick Sager Bloom's District
who says he was unaware of the concerns
but now after you reached out to me I
will call our Public Works forever they
went out and looked at it they say that
we can uh it's maybe so serious we're
gonna have to redo the road at some
point but we can try to level it out in
the meantime we got to do it now before
it gets even worse
now besides the apology commissioner
Seger Bloom directs people to the
district email and The Fix It app to
report any road concerns and you can
find those on our website later tonight
8 News now.com reporting live on Vegas
Valley Boulevard near lamb Ryan Matthey
a news now thank you Ryan now Les Schwab
says hitting potholes can inflict a host
of problems to your car so if you can't
avoid one they say take your foot off
the gas hold your steering wheel tightly
do not break this allows you to maintain
the most control during the impact